men though are losing interest in almost
all of society and this is what I worry
about the most so you know people look
at people talk about suicide rate right
people are looking at uh they're like oh
social media is driving teen girl
suicide I'm not saying it's not a
problem but males commit suicide at four
times the rate that women do or if you
look at right now we're better okay
yeah
that's what I'm saying we're going to be
better so we use more actually the real
reason is that most men shoot themselves
in the head and then women there's
something about the way that women I
don't by the way Suicide Hotline Etc if
you need help do that okay so
I don't need to be
easy
put on some [__] Nations Avenue and
you're gonna feel so better actually
Ocean Avenue is a great job
if you're thinking about doing it dude I
do just cover one eye with some hair and
go out there and take on the dishes okay
come on dude Ryan shackler can do it
wait can you
look up the ways that men kill
themselves in the way that women kill
themselves so yeah from what I
understand it women are more likely to
take pills something that doesn't
involve like I guess like messing with
their beautification it's cute because
like if you think about you know it's
like a gruesome action I still want to
be pretty yes there's something about
that where you're much more likely to
take pills and like men are just very
much more likely to reach for the God
we're efficient we're very efficient
problem with that though is the male
suicide rate is very high single men are
dropping out of college out of his by
the way the gender disparity right now
in college is [__] insane we're
talking like 60 40 for incoming freshman
classes yeah but isn't this like we're
we've realized that it's just not worth
it yeah but that's not that's a problem
though because a lot of women who have
college degrees do not want to date men
who don't have college degrees until
they make some money okay but that's the
issue right when you don't have a
four-year college degree you're not
going to make enough money to be a
desirable mate and so right now in terms
of what we're seeing a lot of women who
have college degrees even if they are
willing to marry somebody who doesn't
have a college degree that person needs
to be like a very high earner like women
make 150 to 200 000 are women making
more than men now at a younger age so
that's a great point so you know 10
years ago what are we here lean in lean
in wage Gap wage Gap wage the wage Gap
right now is [__] like uh you can
pull this up miles please which is that
women are outside right there okay all
right I've been Googling my ass off wait
a minute all right women now out earning
men in major cities so this is good yeah
okay but we solved it like we're good
you don't need to hear it anymore like
now we have a actual gender disparity
crisis yes boys and men are like not
going to college making less money
killing themselves at high rates don't
have yeah there you go in New York City
young women young women now are out
earned men especially under 30. the way
that everybody talks about them I agree
with you but to be fair this says in 22
of 250 cities that means in 10 of cities
yeah but what percent GDP is
concentrated in those 22 cities like
we're looking at New York City Chicago
San Francisco
[Music]
you can't really say concentrated but
you got me on that point though
yeah
even concentrated what did I say
conflict it was something yeah my hair
dropped on that one GDP I like that all
right Suicide Hotline bro yeah it's not
good this is not good
at me for saying no bless oblige what
does that mean what do you think it
means no blessing no bless oblige break
it down no bless no bless oblige oblige
is like uh obligated obligation so
what's no bless nobility so it's like
the obligation of nobility so the idea
of no bless oblige is the responsibility
of privileged people to act with General
the idea was is that if you were it's
like that with great power comes great
responsibility so it's like no actually
it's the opposite yo you're a [__]
idiot
hey dude stop acting like you know
things yeah we've got a guy that know
things right here let's just [__]
listen to him and explain our French
things like there's no [__] getting
guys
come on dude that time I knew I was
wrong for the record and the other time
I'm not being defensive about it dude
come on dude come on dude it is bro no
we got one here that's thank God no
bless her bleach bro come on okay wait a
minute you were saying so young kids are
being gay or something uh actually I'm
not sure if that well that's a separate
issue okay is there a higher rate I mean
you could if you guys want to get into
it we can look at the uh let's finish
this point
finish this point
how many young pole smokers
[Laughter]
young people are having dramatically
less sex than they ever have old people
too
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait can someone pull those stats up for
me
don't call me a stats don't call me a
stats
you really should do screen mirroring
because
chill out yeah
white boy
oh dude
all right so what do we got come on bro
what'd you write
the answer Tom Jr blast low Texas
journalist
wait a minute you're from Texas and
you're a
journalistic really dude come on Brooke
come on dude all right don't tell me uh
pull up the amount not men having sex
just young people having less sex so
yeah there is actually young people are
engaging in like less risky activity
young people are having less sex they're
not you think it's possible young people
are just being honest now because that's
valuable possible like in the 80s if you
yeah but the teen pregnancy rate was
actually pretty well I guess if you
think about it abortion was legal then
so I don't actually know there you go
why today's teens are having so much
less sex in America are having less sex
than young people used to courtship and
sexual changes have frequently
accompanied disruptive Technologies yes
I don't blame technology actually I'm
not sure that that's right
I really don't know I I think a lot of
it comes down to like just it's like you
said there's like a lack of national
Vision projects they're doing less drugs
well no they're doing a pot they're
doing more pot less drinking bro this is
it with the sex and the courtship all
right
guys didn't know how good dick tasted
right well
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
back in the day before social media
girls had access to the dudes that would
hit on them right they couldn't just be
with an NBA star because you had to be
[__] Shameless to be with an NBA star
you have to be Shameless you have to go
to their hotel you have to like the
Yellow Pages no self-respecting girls
gonna go to a guy's hotel room and just
wake but that's how you met them back in
the day right or you like knew another
famous person hopefully you were invited
to some party where maybe they were
there and then you shamelessly approach
them now they're just dming you so the
average girl has access to so many more
uh successful guys than they did back in
the day so I think uh younger guys are
competing with NBA stars younger guys
are competing with you know singers and
rappers and all this other [__] and it's
a lot more difficult for something to
that I think that's it man on social
media
get like 90 of the swipe someone needs
to pull up whatever it is the point is
the point is this is back in the day
when someone needs to pull up stuff
we're gonna bring it out here